[Musique]
ce gâteau il ya une petite particularité
c'est que j'ai ouvert complètement
l'intérieur et j'ai glissé des petits nm
ce don quand on va le coupé il y aura
une petite cascade de menace à
l'intérieur ce sera la surprise pour les
enfants elle appuie pâtissière diplômée
depuis l'an dernier élabore la dernière
étape de slayer cake la décoration sur
un thème original le dessin animé la
pâte patrouille tous les personnages
sont 1 pâte à sucre
on me demande pas mal des thèmes jungle
forêt
j'ai déjà eu
quelques autres un petit renard un
animal une baleine ce genre de choses si
rennes aussi c'est un gros en ce moment
où il demande beaucoup de sirène cela
fait un mois que cette pâtissière vient
d'obtenir son tout nouveau laboratoire
de pâtisserie basée à mézy-sur-seine ici
elle réalise des cakes design des
gâteaux personnaliser selon vos envies
un des derniers foyers demandé c'était
un peu le thème gatsby donc je n'avais
pas trop de pas trop d'infos autre que
du blanc du or un peu les années folles
donc donc c'est plutôt chouette heures
moi j'aime bien comment je sais c'est
toujours un challenge à ce genre de
choses parce que parce que ça fait un
peu travaillé mon imagination alors je
regarde beaucoup je je je je regarde un
peu sur internet je regarde un peu
à quoi ça ressemblait pied de la jeu de
la juger des idées qui viennent un layer
cake se fait en plusieurs étapes
puisqu'il y a des grands en offrait tout
est fait maison génoise crème ou encore
coulis on peut tout imaginer dedans il
faut compter 6 euros 50 minimum la part
pour un gâteau classique moi ce que
j'aime dans ce que je fais c'est
vraiment créer inventer c'est à dire ne
pas juste faire de la pâtisserie
traditionnelle parce qu'elle se fait
très très bien dans beaucoup de
pâtisseries mais c'est vraiment créer
quelque chose d'un peu grandiose et qui
remet un peu plein la vue aux jambes la
pâtissière fait également des pièces
montées ou encore des sweet people elle
réalise sur une table le goûter en
entier avec des cupcakes des cookies ou
encore des nems de requêtes
[Musique]